[Music]
hey bleacher report i'm michael carter
williams taking on mike smith
in mike's hard lemonade seltzer's battle
of the mics nobody makes lemonade like
mike's
they are the experts so we're going
against each other in a trivia challenge
to see who's the expert mike
when did i win rookie of the year 2014.
correct 2014 man that seemed like a long
time ago what's my career high assist
in a single game you know at michigan
you're just dropping some dimes so i'm
gonna go with
15. this guy's cheating yes that's
correct
when i get it right is my career high
points over or under 25
[Music]
over it is over but you took a little
too long like you could have answered
over like
right after i was done my fault bro i
didn't mean that i didn't
do that i had over under 400
assists in college if your career has 15
assists in the game i'm definitely going
over
oh man what age was i when i first
dunked
15. my first dunk i was about 16 almost
17 years old
i was close you should just give it to
me just like my former coach which city
am i from but i know your former coach
is from
illinois so i mean i'm gonna go with
chicago
what city is it it's burr ridge and you
want to talk about hard questions which
season did i switch to braids
um 2017 2018 season
nope wrong just for the game win are you
ready
for the tie breaker true or false i've
scored double figures and more than 90
games in college
i want to thank my teammates my family
couldn't have done this without y'all
beat mike in this trivia contest
just answer the question there i'm gonna
go with truth
since you average about nine points a
game i mean i'm not going to call him a
cheater but
ah man can't even give you the dub i
didn't get it true or false
we're all tied up watch me take it all
in episode three
so he thinks